so Messi is going to Miami but how can
they afford him the World Cup winner
turned out a staggering two billion
dollars from Saudi club alcohol but
Major League Soccer offers him something
a little bit different he'll still earn
around 50 million dollars a year but
it's reported he'll also get a slice of
Apple TV's MLS subscription money
another of the league sponsors Adidas
would also share any extra profit they
make from his involvement and oh yeah he
can also become a part owner of inter
Miami itself alongside Club president
David Beckham it's also a good fit for
the messy family who already own
property and holiday in Miami and what a
boost for the MLS their highest profile
signing since Beckham joined LA Galaxy
from Real Madrid back in 2007. now
Messi's contract could last three years
which would keep him Stateside during
the 2026 World Cup which the US is
co-hosting with Mexico and Canada now
the 35 year old lifted the trophy in
Qatar last year and he said that would
be his last World Cup but now he's Miami
bound you never know
foreign